apple is gonna completely revolutionize
the ipad pro later this year with their
brand new redesigned m2 model that is
gonna have some changes that you were
totally not expecting not only on the
ipad side but also on the magic keyboard
side and they might even give us a brand
new larger sized ipad which is extremely
unexpected but before i talk about that
new 14.1 inch ipad i've got to go
through all of the leaks and rumors that
we have for the m2 ipad pro that we're
going to get here in a couple of months
so let's dig in first of all just a
couple of days ago mark german gave us a
brand new report talking about new ipad
pro models with the m2 chip yes the same
m2 that apple just revealed at wwdc that
they're putting into the macbook air and
the macbook pro that chip is going into
these new ipad pro models not only that
but he's saying that we're gonna get
wireless charging yes wireless charging
on an ipad which sounds weird but i am
gonna explain with some actual apple
patent filings and he's saying that it's
gonna be coming in either september or
october but getting into the whole
wireless charging for ipad pro thing the
first time he mentioned it was back in
december when he mentioned that this
year we would be getting an ipad air 5
an ipad 10 and of course some new ipad
pros but it would have wireless charging
now we actually came back and gave us an
update in march saying that the ipad pro
was still launching fall 2022 with an m2
chip yes he still agrees and max save
charging now if you know anything about
mac save charging apple actually has two
versions that they like to use right now
but the one he was talking about was
actually the wireless aspect so yes the
same max saved charging that we have on
the back of the iphone he said would be
coming to the ipad pro and the way i
know that for sure is because he made a
report back on june 3rd of last year he
said it would feature both wireless
charging and reverse wireless charging
capabilities so essentially his main
point was that the new ipad pro would
have a glass back which would allow the
mac safe to work so you would actually
be able to charge the ipad pro but also
charge other accessories like for
example putting your iphone on the back
of the ipad your earpods or other
accessories by laying them on the back
of the ipad and of course with the
magnetic connection that would allow you
to use it and have something charging at
the same time and by the way almost a
year ago i made a video talking about
the ipad pro getting max saved charging
as you can see in this thumbnail image
with the actual puck charging the ipad
pro through the magic keyboard not only
that but it made another one about five
months ago showing how airpods will
actually be charging on the back of the
ipad pro which is actually very
convenient however we had some issues
when on january 14th 9to5 mac came out
with an exclusive report saying that
apple hit some roadblocks with its plans
to redesign the ipad pro with mac save
because it was said that the glass back
was too weak and because of the risk to
damage it and crack the glass apple may
have scrapped their plans for the glass
back so because of that they said
there's a chance that apple could be
making a larger apple logo
made out of glass and the actual mac
save puck would connect through that
logo so the whole back would actually be
metal except for that little glass logo
so i worked with renders by shy less to
create some new ipad pro renders showing
off a larger apple logo as you can see
this one is quite a bit larger and
here is the mac safe puck on the back
just perfectly slotting into place and
charging it however we have been getting
some reports and speculations from some
people like bob on twitter who says it's
coming in october and he believes it's
actually going to be max safe three so i
asked him why he believes max a3 and he
says he heard about max save coming on
the ipad pro but max a from the iphone
does not make sense especially because
of the magic keyboard case now i
disagree with him because i believe the
magic keyboard case might get max save
which i'm going to get into in just a
moment but he says that max 83 would
give you a free port while charging
which is especially useful since the
ipad pro only has one port so i would
agree that would actually make it nice
and the cool thing about that is that i
actually made a video about six months
ago showing off that idea of mac safe 3
on the side of the ipad pro and i made
that video because we actually had some
interesting cads that were leaked i
believe from x leaks showing off these
little connectors on the side of the
ipad pro which could point to mac save 3
but honestly in my opinion i think the
wireless charging mac safe makes more
sense because you'll be able to reverse
wireless charge your other mac safe
accessories and mark german has been
talking about wireless more than he has
about wired now before i get into all
those magic keyboard patents and leaks i
want to talk about the release date for
the actual m2 ipad pro because mark
german believes it's coming in september
or october and i'm going full force with
october because i believe the ipad pro
is on a one and a half year upgrade
cycle or timeline and according to this
timeline of all the ipad models you can
see that from this ipad pro to the next
one was around a year and a half and
then again from here to here around a
year and a half once again around a year
and a half now this model the 2020 going
to the m1 was only one year which was a
little bit weird but as you all know
it's already been over one year since
the m1 ipad pro was released so if we
wait until october that would go back to
the one and a half year timeline and i
don't think it's gonna get delayed to
around two years in the spring of 2023
so i am sure that it's coming this fall
likely in october now moving on to some
more leaks there was a twitter user who
asked majin buu who was a pretty
reliable leaker if the 11 inch ipad pro
coming this year is getting mini led and
he said no it is not he said maybe next
year but not right now and that is
interesting because minchikwo last year
in july actually said that the 11 inch
model was gonna feature the mini led
display but majin buu says that is not
gonna happen and not only that but ross
young who is the most reliable display
analyst and leaker for apple products
actually came out with his new super
follower program which is five dollars a
month where he gives us exclusive leaks
and he replies to tweets so i asked him
is mini led coming on the 11 inch ipad
pro this year and he says no apple is
going to be focusing mini led on the
12.9 inch and larger ipads and macbook
pros so he agrees with imagine boo and
now another topic i want to talk about
in terms of this year's ipad pros is
actually the potential for a new smaller
apple pencil which john prosser from
front page tech leaked and talked about
saying that this new leaked apple pencil
from mr white is actually shorter than
the current one which means that apple
could actually be working on a new one
for this year's ipad pro releases so
let's wait and hope for that but now
let's get into those magic keyboard
patents by apple as you can see last
year actually maybe in 2020 apple won a
patent for a next-gen magic keyboard
featuring a retainer and wireless
recharger for the apple pencil as you
can see it shows the apple pencil system
where it retains it and recharges it
within the actual magic keyboard case
hinge and not only that but this new
updated magic keyboard case features a
double hinge as you can see there's one
hinge right here and one right here in
this image which allows you to fold the
entire keyboard case backward to have a
nice level surface for drawing taking
notes and everything else you would need
so that would be the second gen magic
keyboard not only that but we got some
actual patents for a mac safe magnetic
core within ipad keyboard cases as you
can see right here it shows the actual
mag safe with the magnetic ring and once
again here's another patent showing a
future magic keyboard with two wireless
power coils that means double the max
safe now it's not going to look like
this because it's not a design patent
it's a utility patent for the actual
technology but it talks about being able
to recharge your devices such as an
iphone apple watch airpods case and more
on the back portion of the keyboard case
which points to reverse wireless
charging with max safe which is exactly
what mark german leaked and talked about
but now finally getting into the reports
of the third larger ipad pro size majin
buu talked about a 14.1 inch ipad m2
with 512 gigs of storage 16 gigs of base
ram alongside the 11 inch and 12.9 inch
ipad pro launching in either october or
november now some people were actually
doubting him but ross young came out and
confirmed that yes apple is in fact
working on a
14.1 inch ipad but it's actually not
what you think now there are a lot of
details including some brand new leaks
about the 14.1 inch ipad and there's a
lot to unpack so i'm gonna leave that
for a totally different video because
this one's already running a little bit
long so if you're not already subscribed
do so right now so you don't miss out on
that fully dedicated 14 inch ipad video
but going back to what i'm completely
sure about we are going to be getting a
new m2 ipad pro in an 11 inch and 12.9
inch size later this year and i think
it's coming in october with the new m2
chip so with that said if you disagree
with any of my takes on this video go
ahead and comment them down below but if
you enjoyed the video click the circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right there and definitely stay tuned
for the dedicated 14-inch ipad video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]